les sciences sociales comme toute
discipline scientifique implique la
maîtrise d'un vocabulaire précis et de
concepts bien défini il est parfois
difficile pour les élèves et les
étudiants qui débute dans les sciences
sociales de bien identifier et
comprendre le vocabulaire important je
m'appelle sylvain armand je suis
professeur de sciences sociales dans le
secondaire supérieur et dans cette vidéo
je vous présente les sept premiers
concepts qu'il faut maîtriser pour
débuter la pratique des sciences
sociales
le premier concept et le concept de
société une société est un ensemble
d'individus qui noue entre eux des
relations de différents types politique
économique familiaux culturels au sein
de différents groupes autrement dit une
société est un système social complexe
parfois ce terme est utilisé un peu
abusivement c'est à dire qu'on l'emploie
comme s'il s'agissait d'une chose en
tant que tel alors que c'est un ensemble
d'individus et de groupes qui agissent
parfois de manière tout à fait
individuel ou isolées par exemple
j'entends souvent des expressions comme
c'est la société qui veut ça la société
est malade ce genre d' usage n'est pas
souhaitée car ce sont des affirmations
qui ne veulent en fait rien dire par
contre on peut très bien parlé d'une
société en tant que système qui lie les
individus entre eux par exemple une
société traditionnelle où il y a peu de
différences entre les personnes ou une
société patriarcale où ce sont les
hommes qui détiennent le pouvoir
ce sont deux utilisation correcte du
terme de société car on cible ici une
organisation sociale et non une chose
qui imposerait des règles aux individus
nous venons dire que la société est un
système de relations entre les individus
ces relations peuvent être de
différentes formes elles peuvent être
politique la politique et la façon dont
une société voir un groupe rend ses
décisions
comment fait-on pour décider ce que l'on
doit faire ensemble
c'est l'objet de la politique la
politique n'est donc pas que des hommes
et des femmes politiques d'ailleurs
beaucoup de choses sont politiques
alors qu'elle n'implique pas des hommes
et des femmes politiques par exemple les
habitants d'un village qui se mobilise
contre un projet d'implantation d'un
centre commercial est un fait politique
les relations peuvent également être
économique quand ils entendent le mot
économique les élèves pensent souvent à
des questions d'argent
c'est une erreur car il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont économiques et dont
l'argent est absent l'économie c'est la
manière dont une société ou un groupe
gère ses ressources et ses besoins
comment fait-on pour produire ce dont on
a besoin comment fait-on pour distribuer
ce que l'on a produit qui peut et
comment consommer ce que l'on a produit
sont les grandes questions économiques
donc des coq auteurs qui réfléchissent à
comment ils vont faire pour se procurer
les biens et les équipements collectifs
comme du papier toilette ou un canapé
pour le cot fond de l'économie au sein
d'une société
les relations sont également d'ordre
culturel en effet les membres d'une même
société ou d'un même groupe ont une
culture plus ou moins commune
il n'est pas question ici du sens
courant du mot culture qui renvoie
l'ensemble des oeuvres et des ouvrages
réalisés par une civilisation dans les
sciences sociales la culture signifie
surtout l'ensemble des valeurs des
normes des comportements partagé par les
membres d'une même société par exemple
la manière de saluer varie d'une société
à l'autre la manière de se comporter à
l'école aussi tout comme la façon de
s'alimenter tout cela correspond à la
culture la culture est donc un ensemble
de normes et de valeurs
les normes sont constitués des règles
officielles c'est à dire des lois et des
règlements comme le règlement d'une
école mais aussi des règles officieuse
qui ne sont pas clairement dit mais que
tout le monde respecte ou presque par
exemple il n'est dit nulle part qu'il ne
faut pas faire de rohan public c'est une
règle officieuse une norme pourtant à
quelques exceptions près beaucoup de
personnes ne font pas de roue en public
même si l on éprouve le besoin les
valeurs sont les principes moraux que
les individus d'une société partage par
exemple dans notre société l'honnêteté
est l'un des grands principes que tout
le monde reconnaît comme important même
si tout le monde n'est pas forcément
toujours honnête d'ailleurs le mensonge
la tricherie ou la fraude qui sont le
contraire de l'honnêteté sont
sanctionnés socialement après ce qui
vient d'être dit on peut se poser
certaines questions en effet au sein
d'une même société on peut constater que
tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes normes
ni les mêmes valeurs ni les mêmes
comportements
bref pas la même culture dans certains
groupes d'ados on rivalise à celui qui
fera le plus gros est dans un groupe de
braconniers ou de malfaiteurs
l'honnêteté ne sera pas toujours
valorisé et sera remplacé par l'honneur
pour répondre à cela il faut d'abord
souligner que même si nous faisons
partie d'une même
anisation et que nous partageons un
socle commun il existe bien évidemment
des différences individuelles qui
proviennent de nos expériences de vie
différente un enfant unique qui est
élevé seule par une maman célibataire
avec peu de ressources
il n'aura pas la même expérience de vie
qu'un enfant issu d'une famille aisée et
nombreuses de plus il faut revenir au
concept de société dont nous avons parlé
de au début de la vidéo je vous avais
dit que la société est un terme très
générale qui comme de nombreuses
subtilités
car au sein d'une société les individus
participe à différents groupes chaque
groupe social comme une famille ou un
groupe d'amis peut avoir sa culture
propre et sa propre organisation
politique et économique ses propres
normes et valeurs même si ce groupe
partagent certains points communs avec
les autres individus composant le reste
de la société chaque groupe constitue si
je peux dire une mini société incluses
dans une société plus vaste un groupe
social peut se définir comme un ensemble
plus ou moins restreint d'individus qui
entretiennent des liens partagent
certaines caractéristiques communes
réalisent ensemble certaines activités
une classe d'élèves dans une école est
par exemple un groupe social en résumé
une société est un système social
composé d'individus réunis dans
différents groupes le système social est
organisée politiquement et
économiquement les membres d'un même
système d'une même société partage
certaines normes valeurs et
comportements
même si des différences peuvent
apparaître à l'échelle des groupes et à
l'échelle individuelle
cette vidéo est terminé il y aura ne
vous inquiétez pas d'autres vidéos qui
présenteront d'autres concepts de base
des sciences sociales et il y en a vous
en trouverez déjà sur le site sociaux
tech.com je vous mets différentes
ressources pour débuter les sciences
sociales dans le descriptif et je vous
dis à très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo
[Musique]